what is going on everybody and welcome
to another deep learning with Python
intense flow and chaos tutorial video in
this video in the coming videos we're
going to be talking about how to apply a
you know recurrent neural network to a
more realistic example of like what
you're actually going to have to go
through if you want to do you know make
a recurrent neural network learn again
some sequential data so in this case
we're going to be working with a time
series data set which is prices in
volumes for crypto currencies if you
wanted you could do it with it you could
follow along and do the exact same thing
with stocks or if you don't like finance
at all no matter what like anytime I do
a finance series people are like I don't
get it
I'll try to be as simple as possible
here there might be some new terms but
it's it's pretty basic stuff it's what's
the price of the the thing and how much
of the thing is being traded at any
given time and what we're going to try
to do is take basically the four major
crypto currencies and that is Bitcoin
litecoin
etherium and Bitcoin cash not
necessarily in that order but can we
take those four crypto currencies and
track their price over time so like the
sequence over time of their price and
their volume and can the recurrent net
basically take sequences of all those
prices and all those volumes so in this
case like let's say we want to predict
the price of light coin into the future
so can we take the last 60 minutes of
light coin price and volume Bitcoin
price and volume aetherium price and
volume and bitcoin cash price and volume
so take the last 60 minutes of all of
that data every minute so this data is
getting updated once every minute so 60
like sequences 60 long of all that data
and can we predict say I don't know 3
minutes into the future what will will
the price of light coin rise or fall
okay so the same thing could be said
maybe you're reading in sensor data to
servers and you're trying to predict
whether a server is gonna you know
overheat or something like that or maybe
you're trying to predict
traffic like traffic to a website and
you've got like time of day and users or
something like that at the end of the
day what we're trying to do is either
predict some sort of classification in
this case is the price going to rise or
fall or you could try to do like a
regression so you could have like that
the activation for the output layer
could be a linear activation and you
could literally try to predict price or
maybe a percentage change so it's all
normalized so anyways something like
this is really complex because you've
got to do so many things to what's going
to be a typical data set so your typical
data set is not you know it's not even
going to be in sequences it's going to
be one long sequence and we have to
build the sequences and then just like
everything else we've got to balance the
data we've got to normalize the data
especially in this case because the
price of litecoin is just different from
the price of Bitcoin as well as the
volume that's going to be traded so we
really want this to be in relative terms
and then we also need to scale the data
and it won't be as simple as it was with
image data where you just div by 255 so
anyways we've got a lot of stuff that
we've got to think about here also with
sequential data doing out-of-sample is a
little bit different challenge so a lot
of stuff for us to cover let's get into
it first of all I've provided the data
set I'll try to remember put a look at
the description but otherwise go to the
text-based version of the tutorial which
definitely will be in the description
and if you scroll down there is a link
to it D I could just copy the address
and let me just will start a thing now
so we'll call this crypto RNN Tut PI yes
and let me just open that up and sublime
so it's at this link just in case I
forget for whatever reason that's where
you can find it beautiful so when you
download that that's just health is
shaping and then it wasn't where it
needed to be anyway once you've done
that now let's see pull this this is
what you'll get you'll get the zip and
then just go ahead and extract it and
then you'll get this crypto data door
and inside of there you've got these
four files each one is basically just
the price in you
dollars of Bitcoin cash bitcoin
aetherium litecoin so if we open up one
of them we can see here so this is a
UNIX timestamp and then I honestly
forget let me check my notes real quick
it is the low high open and close and
then volume you do not need to
understand what open high low close is
just understand that closes the price at
the end of that 60 second interval
that's the price so we're gonna treat
the closed column as hey that's the
that's the actual price column that
we're gonna use and then the last one
there is volume okay so what we want to
do first is just check out the data and
read it in make sure we've got that
working the way we intend so I'm gonna
go ahead and import pandas as PD we're
going to be using pandas if you don't
have it open up a terminal command
prompt pip install pandas okay so we're
gonna use pandas and we're gonna say DF
equals PD read underscore CSV and the
CSV is in crypto underscore data and
then it is we're gonna go with LTC USD
dot CSV and then if you recall here the
the columns aren't actually named here I
just spit them out from a database so
we're going to use names equals and then
we specify a list of names here and that
is time and then it went low it's
probably gonna go off-screen huh let's
do this beautiful low hi open what's
going on there
why oh we didn't close off low okay low
high open and then it was closed and
then the last column is volume so we'll
read those in and then let's go ahead
and just print the head of this data
frame
that's its shift-enter okay all right so
we have the data read in I have to fix
this is over like by pixels there we go
okay so now we've got the data read in
and we can kind of see what's going on
and again we're really only going to
concern ourselves with the clothes in
the volume but the other thing we need
to be able to do is we basically we have
all this data in different CSVs right
and what we want to do is get the
clothes and the volume for each of them
and they all share the same index which
is time they're all or all this data is
organized by time so we can join all
these data frames on the shared you know
access that is time so the way I'm going
to do that is the following so we're
just gonna say main DF equals Pantone
OPD dot data frame and it's just an
empty data frame for now there has to be
a better way to do this I just I don't
really know it this is the method I
always used for this but there's
probably a better way to to merge data
frames than what I'm about to do but so
must one ratios so this will be the
files that we intend to use so we're
gonna use BTC USD we're gonna use LTC
USD for litecoin we're gonna use
aetherium USD and then we're going to
use Bitcoin cash bch USD then what we're
gonna do is for ratio in ratios we want
to iterate over these ratios so we're
gonna say for ratio in ratios I think
we're just gonna rename ratio here so
ratio will equal ratio let me think
you're so hmm I actually noticed an
issue so what we because we really
really want to do is have to fix that in
my notes I have it wrong okay I'm just
so like if we just print ratio I think
what I had done initially was I used oh
s lister to iterate through the director
and then later I decided to change that
and just manually type it in so I think
that's what happened there anyway we
were about to do a silly split that
didn't make any sense anyways we're
gonna say the data set equals and I've
started to use f strings so we're gonna
use f strings so that would be actually
its crypto data crypto data slash and
then whatever that ratio is dot CSV then
we want to read in with these same names
that we had before so I'm gonna copy
oh so what we need to do is so that's
our data set we're gonna say PD or D F
equals PD read CSV we're gonna read in
the data set and then the names are the
same names as before and in fact I'm
just gonna delete now once we don't
really need that one anymore so we'll
read in that data we've got a data frame
and just for good measure let me make
sure we got what we expected here
invalid sinto we got two two commas what
an amateur ok so we've got the data
frame so this is like each singular data
frame and we want to merge them all so
there's a few things we have to do first
of all we need to set time as the index
like I said before we're really only
gonna focus on the close price and
volume but if we try to join these data
frames together they share these names
like these names are identical so what
we want to do is give them unique
identifying callin names so that we when
we join them we don't get bunch of
errors because we have like columns that
are named identically plus we want to
know which column is which so what we
want to do now is go ahead and I'm just
we're not we don't need to print the
head every time I don't think so we'll
do DF equals and actually I think we can
do it in place equals true here D F dot
rename columns equals and then it's a
dictionary to rename so we want to
rename we want to rename the closed
column to be and again we'll use F
strings and we'll call will do this
ratio underscore close and then we'll do
the exact same thing with volume so
we'll say
volume now becomes an F string what do
we want ratio close or ratio volume so
ratio underscore volume so we've renamed
those those columns the next thing we
want to do oh don't forget the in place
it was true in place equals true and
that's just so we don't have to redefine
dataframe just in case anybody doesn't
know what in place means so then what we
want to do is set the index so DF dot
set underscore index and we're gonna
make that to be whatever the top of the
actual time column and again we want to
in place equals true and now we're going
to specify that the data frame is
actually just the these two columns here
so we'll just copy paste and paste okay
so now this data frame is just the you
know close and the volume and what we
can do now is just to make sure it's
always a good idea just to continually
print out make sure you're doing things
the way that you expect I keep doing
shift enter from I wrote it all like the
my notes in an eye Python notebook so
I'm used to shift enter is running it
rather than control B okay so as you can
see we've got all the columns that we
need and now we want to merge them all
together with each other so the way that
we're going to do that is with a simple
question of if Len m main DF equals 0 ie
it's empty main DF becomes DF and then
otherwise else what we want to do is
main DF equals main DF join DF then
we'll come down here and then a let's
print main DF dot head run that one
truncated all over silly columns so what
we could say is foresee in the F dot
columns it's actually main D F comma
let's print C just make sure we got all
the columns we're expecting sure do
ok great so now we've got that the next
thing that we need to start thinking
about is okay so this is all just
sequential data right so for any you
know supervised machine learning problem
we actually need two things we need the
sequences themselves and then we also
need targets so we need to figure out
okay how are we coming how are we gonna
go out making those targets and then
from there okay what are the targets so
we need to specify some starting some
starting constants so we're gonna say
sequent we're gonna have something for a
sequence length we're gonna need
something for the future period predict
predict and then we need something for
ratio to predict so what are we gonna
try to predict like which one of these
four things are we gonna try so for now
we'll go with litecoin so LTC USD the
future period like how many periods
forward and every period here is one
minute so we're gonna say three minutes
and we're gonna use the last 60 minutes
of pricing data to try to make that
prediction so if you were to you know
yourself look at a graph of the last 60
minutes of pricing and it's updated once
a minute logically you could probably do
pretty good predicting out the next
three minutes but maybe not he's
probably still at fifty fifty actually
if most people sat down but we could
believe that
that sounds begins to sound reasonable
especially if it's not just the last 60
minutes of the single asset that's
litecoin it's the last 60 minutes of
Bitcoin litecoin aetherium and Bitcoin
cash and the volume and all that so
probably a machine could at least do a
little better than a human how much
better we'll see
so once we have that we need to
the actual targets and basically a rule
for the targets so we're going to define
classify and this would be basically our
classification so what we're going to do
is take the current price and then the
future price whatever those happen to be
and then the question is pretty simple
if float current is greater greater than
float future so if the current price and
I don't really like the way I've worded
this let me do if floats future is
greater than float current so if the
price is higher in the future than it is
right now in our training data then
we're gonna say those features were a 1
else else will return 0 and we'll say 1
is a good thing 1 means you should buy
this so we want to train the network
that you know based on these the
sequence of features in general with
this sequence of features price goes up
here and with this sequence of feature
price goes down here and so on so we're
hoping that the model can learn that
relationship
so now we'll come down here to this main
DF and what we can say is main
underscore DF future because we need to
get the future price equals main DF and
then what we want to do is another F
string and we're looking for the ratio
to predict underscore close right the
thing to the future price is going to be
based on that closed column and then
what we want to do is shift that close
column these are like up however many
future predict you know how many periods
forward we want to predict so that's
going to be a negative future period
predict and then let's let's print that
unfortunately I think it's only going to
show us like two columns which is really
annoying
what did we screw up here oh okay
fix the curly brace there that's the
variable okay try again so that's the
future price of light coin unfortunately
we're not showing light coin so I'm
curious if I can get away with the
following so we want to show future and
we want to show this price right here
this column at least right here we just
want to make sure again this stuff shoot
what have I done there we go
especially when you're working with data
like this so this should be the price in
three periods so here and then three
eight this is the price so so currently
the price is this but three periods in
the future it's gonna be this and sure
enough there it is there and then the
same thing here here's the current price
in the future though it's gonna be this
price and we can see that is the case
here again this is you just have to
always be checking every step of the way
it's so easy to make mistake I'll be
really surprised if after I'm ollie you
know completely done with this tutorial
and post it up that there isn't a
mistake in this code because it's just
so easy to make mistakes on doing stuff
like this anyway it looks right so far
so now we want we've got the future
price now what we want to do is map this
function to to a new column that we're
going to call target so we're gonna say
main DF target equals list this just
converts the output to a list that we're
just going to assign as a column so list
and then we're going to map something
what are we going to map we're going to
map that classify function and then
after the function is just each of the
parameters so in this case it's the
current column in the future column so
the the current column is main DF this
right here so it should be main dia boom
so the close column and then we want the
future column so main DF
future and then I'm going to cut this
here paste and let's see if we can get
away with target and then again we're
just trying to see does it work as we
expected so here we can see here's the
current price here's the price in three
periods in the future that's less than
the current price therefore the target
is zero good let's see if we can't print
a little more so let's do ten ten values
for the head here okay so in it so this
is the only one that to buy so here's
the current price but three periods in
the future it's this 4/7 so yeah ninety
six point four seven which is true so
based on the features here hey we want
it to know that's a one okay so at this
point looks great we're ready to make
some sequences and train the model well
well so down so down there Carl we have
a lot more to do so we still have to
build the sequences we still have to
balance the data we still also have to
normalize the data because the prices
and volumes of laQuan are very different
from Bitcoin and then we also still have
to scale the data and probably a bunch
of other things that I'm forgetting
right now like out-of-sample so we have
a lot of work ahead of us so I'm gonna
stop it here and carry on in the next
tutorial
with the the next steps that we have to
do so if you've got questions comments
concerns if I've got an error in the
code you think up to this point you know
feel free to leave those below also a
coat to the most recent sponsors boom
Billy harsh soft Mark Zuckerberg JT and
Newcastle geek I keep seeing Newcastle
geek I don't know if if if the
memberships on YouTube are updated each
you know each time if you stay a member
or not because I feel like the only
person I keep seeing over and over is
Newcastle geek and I don't maybe
everyone's like remember becoming
members and they're not I don't really
know but I keep seeing that name so
anyways that's it for now and thanks
again for you guys
becoming members I appreciate the
support and I will see everybody else in
the next video